after criticizing
the organization of the world cup
by the qatar
including on the fate of migrant workers
who have died by the thousands on the construction sites
now France is
she too
in the face of a controversy over the organization of the jo
deux-mille-vingt-quatre
liberation met with undocumented workers
who are employed by a subcontractor company
who works
on the construction sites of the jodeux-mille-vingt-quatre
among them there are handlers
in charge of carrying bags of cement
of more than ten kilos on thirteen floors
there are branchers
specialized in reinforced concrete construction
then there are men who do everything and pick up the earth
build the walls
make masonry
all for a little over eighty euros
not reported per day
regardless of weather conditions and one hundred days off
the workers are outraged they have no right
no site maintenance
no safety shoes
we don't pay for their navigago pass
have no medical examination and not even signed a contract
they get sick or hurt
the boss replaces them the next day
one of the workers even stated that on the site
there are almost only foreigners
Pakistani for electricity
Arabs for plumbing
endorsements for masonry
what do you think all this
give us your opinion in comments